the president of Ukraine
[Music]
it's a great honor for me to be at the
U.S Congress and speak to you and all
Americans
against
All Odds and doom and gloom
scenarius Ukraine didn't fall
Ukraine is alive
and Kicking
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for both Financial packages
you have already provided us with and
the ones you may be willing to decide on
your money is not charity
is an investment in the global security
and democracy that we handle in the most
responsible way just like the brave
American soldiers which held their lines
and fought back Hitler's forces during
the Christmas of 1944 Brave Ukrainian
soldiers are doing the same to Putin's
forces this Christmas
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you